if you were to mix 24 The Hangover and
American Pie you'd probably get
obliterated Netflix's new runchy action
adventure with more prosthetic wieners
than an episode of Game of Thrones in
this video we're going to take a quick
look at its ending how Vegas was
ultimately saved and some of the show's
biggest twists and turns but before we
begin make sure to like And subscribe I
plan on visiting Vegas for uh research
the events of the show actually start 6
months ago director of the CIA James
langon has assembled the best of the
best from various branches of the
military their aim is to take down a
group of terrorists hellbent on
exploding a nuke on us soil the culprit
Ivan klov a Russian arms dealer whose
parents and sister were killed by an
American Air strick so he has a personal
Vendetta against America led by top CIA
intelligence officer Ava Winters the
team's goals to take down klov before he
can sell this portable nuke to the
highest bidder fast forward 6 months and
the team's work has all led up up to
this one key moment klov plans on
selling the nuke to a group of Crypt
billionaires they want to use this nuke
to knock out a chunk of American
currency so that their crypto would
Skyrocket what the team doesn't know
however is that this nuke is a fake klov
actually wanted to sell this nuke twice
a fake one and a real one so when the
team successfully takes him down they
realize the real nuke is still out there
and it's counting down 9 hours until
this thing goes boom enter Vlad litvin
kav's Courier Who currently has the real
nuke he plans on selling it to a man
named Wade Maddox an ex-military
contractor who was presumed dead back in
2009 unlike the Crypt Bros who want to
set off a nuke for their own financial
gain maddox's motivation for a blitting
Las Vegas is much more ideological in
episode 6 we'll see him talking to a
group of very powerful and influential
Mass individuals they see the current
culture War between the far right and
far left as destroying America so they
plan on exploiting this weakness to
actually take down America and start a
nuke how exactly do they plan on doing
this by setting up the nuke they plan on
using their ability to manipulate social
media to blame both the right and left
for this bomb going off essentially
pitting these two sides against each
other and plunging the nation into Civil
War and with this group's vast resources
they can swoop in and give the country
the reboot it so desperately need needs
as you can imagine the deal between
Maddox and klov doesn't go as planned
and Maddox ends up taking the nuke by
force with our team failing at every
turn but arguably the show's biggest
twist happens at the end of episode 6
when it looks like the team has Tracked
Down Maddox and the whereabouts of the
nuke they find that he's been killed and
who killed him none other than the Dy
bimbo Lana well she's not actually a d
see bimbo at all she's Anastasia klov
Ivan kof's sister who was presumed dead
in that air strike years ago with her
now in possession of the nuke she plans
to trade it in for the release of her
brother to make matters worse Ava and
her team have screwed up the job so much
they've been taken off the mission
replaced by FBI special agent Ferguson
he'll be the one to arrange this
exchange the nuke for cosw an exchange
which happens in broad daylight on the
Strip but this is all part of Anna's
plan she has a plane carrying a crate of
money explode over the exchange causing
complete pandemonium in the chaos Anna
kills Ferguson and Ava takes down klof
with Anna escaping on motorcycle with
the nuke this leads us to The Season's
final episode with her brother dead Anna
has nothing to live for the Americans
have killed her entire family and she
wants nothing more than for this nuke to
go off so it's a bit of a waiting game
as there's less than an hour before the
this thing blows Anna holds herself up
in a hotel with a ton of Hired Guns as
our team infiltrates the building to
stop this catastrophic attack but this
is secretly what Anna wants that's
because Anna doesn't have the bomb when
Ava and the team finally subdue her
they're surprised when there's no bomb
in the case with a bit of deduction Ava
is able to find out that Anna placed the
bomb in a slot machine Bound for the
plaza casino with less than 20 minutes
left the team has to find out which one
of these machines has the bomb and since
their bomb diffuser is Mia it's up to
Paul to sacrifice himself by taking the
bomb in his Chopper and having it
explode in the desert with literally
hundreds of slot machines the bomb could
be in on the gaming floor Maya the
techner deduces that in order for the
machine to fit that bomb part most of
its components would have to have been
taken out thus she hacks into the gaming
server and makes all the machines go
into jackpot mode meaning the one
machine that doesn't work is the one
that has the bomb in it with only 3
minutes left they find the bomb and Paul
is ready to make his sacrifice that is
before Haggerty the bomb guy shows up on
a camel after a tense buildup he's able
to diffuse the bomb with only a matter
of seconds left saving Vegas and making
our team Heroes and just like the show
started with a giant ass party so too
does it end many of our characters
learned a lot about themselves over the
course of this adventure Paul has
learned to spend more time with his
daughter and accept her weird boyfriend
my learns to stop obsessing over Chad
and Ava and Chad Embrace that even
though they're complete opposites have
genuine feelings for each other but what
did you think of obliterated is this
bomb a dud let me know in the comments
below thanks for watching be sure to
like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstory YT until next
time remember no no no titties in here
B